وقال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي ان الحكمه
تقتضي معرفه كيفيه اداره الامور واختيار
الردود الصحيحه في مختلف المواقف وزعم
نتنياهو ان اطرافا اسرائيليه تسعى لرضاء
الداخل او الخارج على حساب المصالح
الحيويه لاسرائيل وامنها القومي بحسب
تعبيره اريد ان اقول لكم شيئا من تجربتي
هناك من يقولون نعم لكل شيء في الوقت الذي
عليهم ان يقولوا لا ويحصلون بذلك على
التصفيق من المجتمع الدولي وهم بذلك
يعرضون امننا القومي للخطر وهناك من
يقولون لا لكل شيء ويحصلون على التصفيق
هنا في الداخل وهؤلاء يعرضون ايضا مصالحنا
الحيويه للخطر وبود ان اقول لكم شيئا من
تجربتي الحكمه هي ان تعرف كيف توجه الدفع
وتعرف متى تقول نعم عندما يكون الامر
ممكنا وتقول لا عند الحاجه